senator Rick Scott represents the state
of Florida he'd like to investigate the
World Health Organization for what it's
done in response to this pandemic
senator thanks so much for coming on
tonight tell us why you believe the
World Health Organization is in part
culpable for this disaster well first
off it just worked for China Communist
China first they said on January 14th in
a tweet that there was no evidence that
there was human to human transmission
lie then they said I kind of think on
the 20th or something China's doing a
great job lie I asked them and then it
went Trump did the right thing by doing
the travel van they attacked Trump for
doing the wrong thing I asked him to do
an investigation of China back in
February I start talking about just like
you did back in January did they ever do
it
no they if they had done their job
everybody would have gotten more ready
we would have shut down this economy and
we would have all these people dead all
over the world so so I want an
investigation I'm on Homeland Security
I've talked to the chairman Ron Johnson
he's agreed to do it we're gonna
investigate why did they do what they
did what was their purpose and and and
why are we as American taxpayers and
giving them some of our dollars yeah I
mean but Bill Gates who is the single
largest donor I think he gives more than
anybody other than United States World
Health Organization he's out there this
week saying the lockdown needs to
continue indefinitely why are the people
affiliated with the World Health
Organization still treated as serious
people when so many of them are liars
and buffoons well first off we one thing
we should never ever buy one more
product from China when you buy a
product from China you have to say
that's that's a group of people all
right that completely lied to us and
force us to shut down our economy and
killed American citizens and Italians
and Spaniards on top of stealing all of
our jobs before they they lie in the
whu-oh is being right up there with them
helping them it paired it whatever
common is trying to say how long are we
then continue to fund this organization
do you think I hope this is the last
year and and by the way not only do I
not want to fund the whu-oh I want first
let's get the information I can't
imagine it's going to get any better
than what we already know but why are we
why are we funding organizations that
are lying to us I think we pay about 21
percent of their budget China is less
won per weight less than 1% of their
budget so what what's going on here why
are they parroting what China's doing
and did they follow their protocol I
doubt that they follow their protocol
from for pandemics I bet the whio didn't
do it and why didn't they do it so and
by the way we've got to create an
American delivery system for pandemics
for protective gear core ventilators for
therapeutic stop this stuff or lying on
China for anything senator thanks so
much for that great to see you tonight